hey we're doing yellow yeah
that's nothing Chris
are you doing yellow put these huh what
are you getting you can't try on
underwear no I'm kid I'm buying them no
I'm buying this one try this on
yeah come on you're oh thank you dude
come on then what get out of here what
you gotta try it on right yeah I'm gonna
try it on with Frye on the underwear I
already know what I'm getting getting
this bro you can't be in here but I have
in here
No get out you doing you're not really
trying too hard to get me out come on
man I gotta put my underwear go go for a
cup
good
look she's selling them here so go
swimming ah thank you
that's right you read not in my fashion
magazines the closure well and Gerlach
causing public sea
the rival gang blue
our rivals yellow for life
step
I'm not just this